[Musique]
c'est une autorité à reconstitutionnel
qui a été créé en 2011 et qui vise à
défendre les droits des citoyens et des
citoyens face aux dysfonctionnements
qu'on peut connaître
au quotidien notamment avec les services
publics vous avez aussi une compétence
liée à tout ce qui va concerner la lutte
contre les discriminations donc là ça
peut concerner toutes les entreprises
publiques comme privé la défense des
droits de l'enfant et de leur intérêt
supérieur une quatrième mission consiste
à accompagner les citoyens les citoyens
face aux éventuellement
déontologie des forces de police au sens
large
[Musique]
tous les citoyens tous les citoyens
toute aussi des entreprises des
associations si elles estiment que dans
leur droit il y a une difficulté c'est
un service public gratuit
confidentielle et à totalement impartial
c'est ce qu'on entend par autorité
administrative indépendante on est
indépendant des pouvoirs politiques ou
économiques en place
c'est effectivement un événement qu'on
organise maintenant c'est la sixième
édition qui est un événement qui se veut
place publique alors donc on a décidé
les vendredis et samedi prochain donc
les 29 et 37 ans de s'installer à
Trappes place des Merisiers place du
marché donc pas de rendez-vous c'est
tout l'intérêt de la démarche c'est
justement d'aller vers les personnes qui
dans leur quotidien pourraient
rencontrer des difficultés au lieu
d'attendre c'est aussi une démission
qu'on remplit mais au lieu d'attendre
dans nos bureaux que la saisine arrive
[Musique]